Slurpee just turned fifty years.
Fuck yeah, we did it.
USA.
We're not all bad.
And I don't know if you guys
celebrated the way I did,
but that weekend around
the Slurpee's original birthdate
7-Eleven had an amazing
promotion going on.
You go into any 7-Eleven,
pay $1.50,
and bring in the container
of your choice
and fill it up
with Slurpee.
And America fucking responded.
People were bringing in,
like, kiddie pools,
trash bags,
Deep Rock jugs of water.
We went nuts.
Here's what I did.
I day drank. I got hammered.
I walked in there
about 1:00 a.m.,
confidently strode
to the register,
and I was, like,
"One pack of Magnum condoms,
please, sir."
He slid the condoms
across the register,
I unwrapped them
out of the cellophane,
and then I just beelined over
to the Slurpee machine.
Just went right up to it.
Just proceeded to fill up
12 Magnum balloons
full of Slurpee,
one after another.
Tied 'em all up,
scooped 'em up in my arms,
and I was like,
"See you at the centennial,
dipshits."